avec les mangas au journaliste et
directeur du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui
bonsoir tellement gros merci d'être avec
nous alors plus de vingt ans après la
fin de son mandat cette candidature du
président ex président bédié ce qu'elle
a créé la surprise en côte d'ivoire
disons que c'est vrai bébé temps après
le décollage et dire et ce à quoi dans
les jours pour le titre puisque j'étais
candidat en 2010 c'est le cas de michael
a appelé ses partisans à voter alassane
ouattara mais vu la composition
politique la cua d'ivoire et quand on
voit encore la moyenne d'âge of conan
bédié à 4 6 ans et alassane ouattra et
la ba 118 laurent gbagbo 75 à l'ancienne
génération qui est un trait de ministre
d'eric aubin et quoi qu'il arrive qu'on
à béziers en s'éjectant dans cette
course à la présidentielle de 2000 jean
quoi réellement en ses chances
il pense que il a fait tellement ils ont
un certain nombre de rattraper puisque
luminaires reconnu que la commune c'est
notre politique à force politique et 20
personnels alors pour lui c'est le
combat de dénigrer ce sera l'occasion
pour lui de réparer un peu tout ce qu'il
a pu coller comme erreurs aussi et amel
et la côte d'ivoire si les conseillers
c'est un peu le leitmotiv a été lancée
au c17 pollution qu'il a pu mettre en
place avec eux
laurent gbagbo du front populaire
ivoirien ça c'est pour la version
officielle mais enfin on peut décemment
se poser la question qu'est ce qui
pousse à un homme de 86 ans puis qui
pourrait un petit peu ce se reposer
peut-être à briguer la présidence est ce
que c'est une histoire de vengeance de
revanche plutôt on se souvient qu'il
avait été chassé du pouvoir par un
putsch à mes souvenirs sont bons
oui tout à fait oui c'est effectivement
c'est vrai que à 86 ans on peut bien
parce que henri konan bédié at elle
ajouté plus en possession de ses
capacités mais on l'a vu à m cette
invention on a vu qu'on avait dit encore
toute sa tête
et puis faut considérer aussi l'aspect
au rallye culturel et même traditionnels
ou de l'afrique
4 6 ans est chez nous on dit que le
vieux c'est un peu le sage c'est un peu
celui qui incarne un peu toute la
sagesse celui qui est à même de pouvoir
prend les décisions a beaucoup de
beaucoup avec cette capacité dans
l'analyse alors à cet âge là on estime
que lever yahoo le vieux cons les
contrastes comme vieillards et est à
même de pouvoir par des décisions
lucides alors c'est un peu tous ses
aspects l'idée traditionnelle et
anthropologique qui pèse ep en sa faveur
donc c'est qu'au niveau du pdci et la
jna parce que jamais comptés on a vu au
temps du président houphouët boigny
l'avait ses paysages mais bon et à
chaque fois elle est et il est candidat
unique candidat naturel du pdc c'est
cette tradition qui veulent me cultiver
au sein de son parti et l'hépatite e
arnaud comparer conte à bédié alors on
l'a souvent présenté comme l'homme je
suis de l'ivoirité
est-ce qu'il a changé écoutez de toutes
les façons il a eu nettement il ya il a
quand même conduit ces concept
d'ivoirité qui selon lui et ses
partisans auraient été galvaudé à
l'origine c'était un concept culturel
qui définit un peu l'ivoirien qui
dispensent ivoiriens des autres
communautés africaines alors mais
maintenant que nous avons un aspect
politique au social
cela a apaisé vraiment en sa défaveur on
dit que aujourd'hui henri konan-bédié et
callacois ivoire était bon écoutez c'est
pas à moi de faire ce commentaire on l'a
vu non les sept des neuf sorties
lapointe et du bois les étrangers plus
le peu dans les mines on est sportif à
son habit traditionnel et ces personnes
était petit doigt comme étant des
étrangers qui personne à qui pourrait
conduire cette nombre des troupes dans
ces régions où l on est exploité voilà
donc l'ivoirité c'est vrai c'est ce
concept aujourd'hui une île encore
d'actualité et il est vraiment pas à la
faveur de haïti
alors quelle politique internationale
pourrait t'il mener mais je pense que
c'est quand même personnalité qui a eu à
diriger la côte d'ivoire
et pendant son 4 4 années voit cinq
années avant le coup
et c'est qu'il y aura le cohabiter tous
et ne pourra pas diriger la côte
d'ivoire comme j'aurais signé tout à
l'heure à 10 ans qui a été mise en place
à un conte à bédié et laurent gbagbo ont
scellé un accord
et cet accord est assorti d'un projet
politique qui est qui s'appelle le
comité n'en sera pas arrêté de
collaboration entre les deux parties
alors on s'est dit que si elle qu'on
avait des médias a gagné ces élections
qu'il aura gouverné la côte d'ivoire
avec une noble international y aura
forcément les hommes qui soit en
capacité dont stéphane la côte d'ivoire
le voit de son rayonnement à
l'international
merci beaucoup clément yao d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle vous êtes
journaliste et directeur du magazine la
flic aujourd'hui merci à vous